today we're talking about another new
star wars game crazy taxi and jet set
radio reboots and game boy games on
switch leaking
sky dance new media has announced that
it is working with lucasfilm games on a
new star wars action adventure game that
will feature an original story sky dance
new media is a division of sky dance
media that was started and is now led by
writer and director amy hennig known for
her work as head writer and creative
director of uncharted 1 through 4. this
isn't the first time hennig has been in
the driver's seat for a new star wars
game in april 2014 henning joined
visceral games to lead development on
project ragtag a third-person
action-adventure star wars game set to
take place after the events of a new
hope however publisher ea canceled the
project alongside the shuttering of
visceral games this new project joins a
long list of other star wars games in
production ubisoft massive is making one
quantic dream is making one reespan is
working on a sequel to star wars jedi
fallen order aspire is remaking knights
of the old republic and bit reactor is
making a new star wars strategy game but
you know who isn't making a new star
wars game sega instead the company is
reportedly working on big budget reboots
of crazy taxi and jet set radio to be
the first titles within the company's
new super game strategy which almost
sounds like a fake name according to a
report from bloomberg it's still early
days for both projects and either one
could be scrapped although it's claimed
that the crazy taxi reboot has been in
development for more than a year and
could be released by 2025 at the latest
as part of the super game initiative
sega's plan is to create triple a
quality titles that can function as a
live service experience with
cross-platform support and online
presence and microtransactions that can
be promoted through regular events this
approach uses epic games fortnite as
inspiration and a template according to
bloomberg's sources and now i'm just
picturing a crazy taxi with virtual
concerts and a battle pass
not really sure how i feel about that
but let me know how you feel about it in
the comments and speaking of retro games
a game boy advance simulator for switch
has reportedly leaked as spotted by
twitter user trash bandicoot love that
name files containing emulators in
development by nintendo europe research
and development originally leaked onto
4chan another twitter user by the name
of rat girlhunter uploaded alleged
camera footage of the emulators booting
up and running on switch although their
account has since been deleted on top of
that pokemon and gaming leaks account
poryleak told kotaku that the emulator
only works on a switch dev kit currently
as for the games that could be emulated
on the software dozens have been tested
so far and include a number of classic
nintendo games and hidden gems some of
these titles include mario kart super
circuit pokemon pinball ruby and
sapphire legend of zelda diminished cap
and kingdom hearts chain of memories
just to name a few this is the nintendo
switch online update that would cause me
to never put my switch down
so i'm really hoping it gets revealed
that the next direct or else i will weep
but alright if you're into call of duty
then you should be on the lookout for
snoop dogg in game because he's
available now just in time for 4 20.
there is also a new patch for eldon ring
out today one of the changes is
increased colossal sword attack speed
and lowered recovery time so if you're a
strength build like me then you might be
excited to hear that but if you're
anything like my brother-in-law this
update ruined his save files so
i'm hoping that doesn't happen to me or
any of you out there if it hasn't
happened already you can find me on
social media at devante chisholm and
i'll see you tomorrow
you